all right so where are you
going it's a pretty simple
question where you
going
what's up with
uh the body moving the way it
does why is it why is it moving that way
what ideas are there that are making the
body move in the way that it's
moving cuz there's a bunch of
ideas that
are creating mutually assured
destruction they're all about a sense of
me and a sense of lack in a sense that I
need
more and I'm unfulfilled I'm not
satisfied and that same thing is
happening at the level of the nation
state and so what's up with
that
what's up with
this right now not being
fulfilled what's up with
the perverted idea
that there's got to be somewhere to go
in order to be
fulfilled where did that belief or idea
originate
some
assumption that was picked
up probably from
childhood probably some
idea picked up by parents or picked up
from parents or from
society picked up which was
that that you
lack that this already is not
fulfillment
and that I can go somewhere and become
fulfilled and so the body
moving to find fulfillment other than
exactly where it
is is leading to all kinds of
perverted
Dynamics across
earth so why is this Stillness not
fulfilling
enough why is just
this just simply what is appearing just
this microphone this
video why is this not
enough
for
obviously if one sits in the Stillness
that they already are it's obvious that
it's already perfect and it's already
free and there's already no entity and
there's no one behind any eyes and it's
already perfect it's already that but if
if one has never sat in that if one
doesn't has no idea what the
unconditioned is then there is only
ideas that are running on the
conditioned and those conditioned ideas
are that I'm an entity in time in space
and I lack and I need and I will go to
whatever ends I need in order to fulfill
that lack which is actually impossible
to fulfill because it's still it's
void
and that same exact thing is happening
at the level of the nation state so
where where is that coming from where is
it going well the nation state has
obviously assumed separation because
there's a border and a border is a line
that is a bound it's a separation it
says that these people are of a certain
nation and these people are of a
different
nation and so because of that now there
is an other ring there's an othering
that's
allowed so people across these imag AR
Border Lines can other each other and
then kill each other or
can just take resources from the other
um without any um holistic
care and that's and that's the same
question where where is that nation
state
going is the
same scale inv variance as the person
which is obviously an illusion because
there's only the
whole the person is just an
appropriation of the
universal and so this question where are
you
going is meant
to dissolve these imaginary ideas which
are complete nonsense completely
conditioned so why is the body moving
the way it is why is the body
moving
to gain something that it's not
missing so it's already whole it's not
missing additional millions of dollars
or additional Properties or luxury goods
or additional clout or followers it's
not missing any of those
things that's just an
imposition it's just an
imagined conditioned idea that is being
imposed on something that is empty and
free and whole
already and so then that empty free
whole already body is now neurotically
moving between
experiences and try trying to extract
for
itself because it believes that it's
separate and that it lacks and that it's
unworthy and it's
unho and so that's what is an apparent
loss of holism so now something that is
organically free
whole empty love Universal that is now
in an assumed contract or
contract position of lack and trying to
fulfill that through all kinds of
neurotic Tendencies and
movements and manipulations and
control it will
never get what it's
going to try to get it never gets it
hint it never gets it
it never ever gets it it's becoming more
and more obvious that the West is
completely duded in the meme that it's
propagated through the culture which is
now spread across the world which is
that you as an individual through
capitalism through a crewing money
through saying [__] all ethics I care
not at all about morality or apparent
others or other nations but instead I
will just extract whatever the [__] I
want for this sense of lack and
unworthiness inside and I will create
whatever unethical business practices I
will create whatever manipulations in
the real estate
economies I will perversely Shu
Pharmaceuticals down people's throats I
will fund military industrial complexes
and be a shareholder of those and get
dividends from
that I will do I will stomp on top of
people's shoulders I will climb up every
single ladder imaginable and just say
[__] you to every single peasant low
life below
me because what I want is this
insatiable appetite to be fulfilled of
all these material possessions of all
this clout and fame
I want all of the women the men to want
me because I'm the highest on the
hierarchy and I'm the one that needs to
be looked up to as most
valuable and there's the rat race
there's the rat race the whole [__]
cycle is right there the whole thing's
right there where are you going where
are you going where are you going circle
circle circle circle circle where are
you going okay next course next
experience next travel next date next
attainment next thing knowledge next
book whatever it is next thing that I'm
going to get that's going to make me
feel whole that's the Trap that's the
Trap circle circle circle circle circle
it'll never end the the amount of
objects that you can objectify that will
try to get you wholeness will never
end and it's the wholeness that already
is and so that's the question where are
you going it's just a rat race it's just
a rat race there's nowhere to go it's
already wholeness you're already nobody
you're already wholeness you're already
everybody you're already the universal
you're already whole you're already free
there's nowhere to
go nothing that you can possibly attain
can be added on to you because you're
already
infinite
so where are you
going you're watching this video so
where are you
going apparently the video popped up
going where are you going do you do you
know know how to just sit can you just
sit in a chair can there just be sitting
in a chair happening can there just be
that or does there have to also be on
top of that oh my gosh I lack I don't
have enough I need more more houses more
material objects more followers more
money I need more I need more look at
all of these [__] Rich ass CEOs and
billionaires and gurus oh my God I need
to be just like them in order for me to
be whole in order for me to be worthy in
order for me to get the approval of my
mom or my dad or in order for me to get
the mate that I
[Music]
want in order for me to get validated
with all the likes and all the
comments and so I incessantly need to
move and I need to move this way and
then I need to move that way and I need
to consume more content and I need to
learn more and I need to be more
[Music]
knowledgeable Rat Race Rat Race Rat
Race spin spin spin spin
spin so the video showed up so what
where are you going where are you going
where is your partner your girlfriend
boyfriend whatever where husband or wife
where are they
going are they trying to get somewhere
are they trying to become fulfilled or
become whole because if one is trying to
become fulfilled they are
inevitably causing mutually assured
destruction you can't become fulfilled
you have you have to be fulfillment
itself you have to be wholeness
itself trying to get wholeness by going
places and getting objects and setting
goals and
attainments that is mutually assured
destruction that's the origin of the
nation state the origin of Separation
the origin of the individual that
lacks the nation state that lacks that
will go to whatever means it needs in
order to get what it
wants which includes the annihilation of
people there's a question in the live
chat about where is this going with the
channel
nowhere
nowhere it doesn't [__] matter it's
already free and whole if this B body is
saying through this channel that it's
already free and whole question where
are you
going that's just what's happening it's
what's appearing on the
channel and that's just what's
happening and if someone's watching this
video which is again always no one
that's watching the video but if
someone's watching the video and there's
the reflection of this question of where
are you going and then that someone
realizes that oh [__] actually I'm
running [__] scripts in my head
about I'm lacking and I need to get more
for this sense of lack and then they
just become the nothing that was already
there then that destroys another pathway
towards mutually sure destruction it's
like a neuron that is no longer firing
in the direction of a nuke on planet
Earth truly the channel is very
directionless and without
orientability period but I will say this
in that last analogy it does seem like
this body is using this channel this
channel one of the ways that it's
manifest is that in that analogy of
there's only these 8 billion apparent
let's say human neurons that are here on
this Earth and that this body's apparent
work one of it the ways that it
manifests is to guide har like through a
harmonic in a way like a dot dot dot
doess wholeness wholeness wholeness love
love love love already fulfilled through
some sort of a mantra like vibration or
frequency to the whole to have these
neurons stop their [__] ideologies
about lack and separ oparation and
fighting each other to create more and
more probability of mutually assured
destruction on this Earth out of
infinity and instead have that pathway
towards mutually assured destruction
self annihilate self dissolve back into
the wholeness that's already there so
the neuron which is what is being used
in this analogy as a body that body's no
longer running on a beine to [__] try
to get more and more like a Hungry Ghost
um more material objects more
experiences more money more houses more
planes more diamonds and
gold I don't care how I get it I will
kill whoever I want to to get it that
thing annihilated that thing listening
to this message has the possibility to
to [__]
relax just [__]
relax you're already whole you're
already free you're already empty
there's no one inside in the first place
you're not a name that is trying to make
a [__] personal brand for itself and
gain mommy and daddy's approval and gain
the approval of others there are no
others everyone is empty there's only
empty ESS behind all
eyes there's only wholeness you are
everyone you are everywhere all at once
your
Infinity this ing Earth
ing there's nothing to
get another comment in the live chat I
love
it I love you
too beautiful
glad there's
resonance
um yeah this is just this is just a
powerful question to ask you know the
the question of where are you going
leads to in many ways the dissolution of
the illusion the illusion being that
there's a me there's a me that lacks
that's the
illusion so the question where are you
going can trigger
the dissolution of an elusory me that is
lacking and trying to get something and
manipulating Earth to try to get what
it's missing which it can never get
because there's a void
inside and that's why there's so many
rich people or so many famous people
that [__] hate themselves and they
can't understand why they're unfulfilled
with so much money or so much Fame how
many [__] examples do you need to see
of rich people or famous people who
[__] hate their
lives you think that it's fun to
constantly be anxious about who [__]
loves you for your [__] quirky ass
goony self versus who's trying to get
money from you versus who's trying to
just get you to [__] post them on
their
stories you think it's fun to have
bodyguards or bulletproof glass or to
have bank accounts in other countries
and always be worried about who the [__]
is [__] you over and trying to steal
your millions of
dollars you think it's fun to [__]
get affiliated with with with child
pedophilia or to get affiliated with
extremely unethical or imoral behavioral
patterns or power trips or ego trips or
narcissistic Tendencies you think those
things are fun none of those things are
fun none of them none of them are fun
it's all obviously happening to nothing
but none of those things are fun so ask
yourself where are you going where am I
going do I do I actually want a yacht do
I actually want a Rolex do I actually
want a private jet do I actually want a
million subscribers or a million
followers do I actually want multiple
millions of dollars do I actually want
multiple properties across earth do I
actually want those
things do I actually want a sports car
do I want those things
really or is it a complete delusional
idea that's just been
implanted there in empty
space and then that thing is now
commanding the body that delusional idea
is commanding the body's movements like
a
zombie any even partially healthily
holistic
non-
entity can
grock that all of what was just said is
extremely unhealthy
patterns
ideas that are running the body into
mutually assured
destruction
there's all of these neurons as bodies
that are Computing that are firing that
are behaving or acting towards mutually
assured destruction because they just
don't care they don't care about Border
Wars they don't care about military
industrial complexes they don't care
about
billionaires I mean in the sense of
acing billions of dollars there's now a
race to be the first trillionaire
there's now a race to be the most click
baity YouTuber that can get a a billion
subscribers
um
the the most uh uh funding of of
military-industrial complexes to have
the greatest weapon
Technologies and this is all the
question where are you going where is
the leader of the nation state
going they're just going balls first
into separation balls first into
separation that's where it's
going you can't sit
still you can't sit still and know that
you don't
exist
you can't sit still and not move and
recognize that the thing that is looking
out your eyes is nothing it's
Freedom it's emptiness it's wholeness
you're everything everywhere all the
time you've never left it you can't
possibly leave it it's forever it's a
done deal it's complete it's here now
and
Timeless absolutely Beyond
yet supremely present to the mundane and
ordinary here it is you can't possibly
leave it it's
this hearing my voice speaking these
words it's
this and because you're avoiding that
you're running like a chicken with your
head cut off like a separate
individual into a world of other
separate individuals that all are have
competing agendas to try to get
themselves the most money
resources women material objects
Weaponry just mutually sure
destruction all because there's been a
complete overlooking of what's already
empty and whole and free and love and
you so it's literally just where are you
going the movement is an idea it's a
program it's just a program that's
running and that program that's running
is absolutely
diluted it's just a program where are
you going it's a program oh I lack an I
need therefore I can get wholeness
through X
object and that's absolutely
inexhaustible because it will go through
infinite objects infinite objects I'll
say it again infinite objects it will go
through just to find that it actually
can never
satiate the void inside through an
object
it can only be the autof fulfilled void
it can only be the whole that it already
is it can only be that it can never fill
it it can never [__] fill it it can
never fill
it it's completely just a stupid program
that is lodged into open
space so it's not even there and that
program
has just completely taken over the body
in all of its delusional Pathways
towards trying to get Hess trying to get
fulfillment and creating all kinds of
mutually assured destruction all kinds
of non wholeness all kinds of me a
separate individual that lacks and that
can get what it's missing through
endless
objectification there's a question in
the live live chat about how do we
deprogram our
conditioning well the the first and
foremost is that there's already no one
that's asking that question so you're
nothing asking about how to
deprogram
conditioning it has to start with
that that's the most direct
pointing because there's infinite ways
that you can quote objectify to try to
decondition
programming
right but it's obvious it's just so
obvious there was some stupid idea that
was inserted at some time into this open
space which is
nothing and that stupid idea is just
obliterated it's just obliterated and
it's it's not even
there it's not even there it's just a
[__] idea of I exist I'm my name I'm
inside of a body those are all separate
people that are separate names that are
inside of their separate bodies and I'm
not them they're not me we're separate
it just so happens that there's
separation inside of what is obviously a
singularity it's [__] [__] it's
[__] [__]
How can there be separation inside of a
singularity it's [__] [__]
there's only a singular Boundless Energy
which is
everything there's another comment in
the chat starts with stopping caring how
others perceive you yeah the [__] there
isn't even an other and there's not even
a you it's just nothing looking at or
talking to itself self who the [__]
cares absolute end of giving a [__]
about anything about
anything and that's why there during
that question about what the Channel's
about the answer was nothing the
Channel's about nowhere the Channel's
about it just is what it is you know if
this stream is coming out in the way
that it is about about where are you
going and wholeness then it's just
appearing like conversations about
wholeness from wholeness to
wholeness and if wholeness isn't a
delusion that it has to deprogram its
belief system which is oh my God I have
to attain a material object in order for
me to be fulfilled that is just a
deluded program and idea and then
there's a being Lo apparently being
locked into a series of thousands of
hours of work or what ever in order to
buy some exuberant flamboyant object
that doesn't [__] matter some stupid
flashy piece of [__] that then is
flashed in front of nothingness' eyes
there are no others there are no others
you're not getting validated by others
you're only flashing that thing that you
suffer thousands of work hours for to
yourself which is emptiness it's [__]
stupid
yes it's just a Hall of Mirrors a hall
of
Reflections whatever you want to
whatever wants to be called however you
want to say it it doesn't [__] matter
how you say it nothing everything it
doesn't matter it just doesn't matter
what matters is nothing but also what
apparently matters what's being said
through this channel is that these
deluded ideas and programs that are
running are the very thing that's
creating mutually assured destruction on
Earth it's the very thing where these
neurons are steam lining straightlining
towards mutually assure destruction
because they don't give a [__] they love
the separation they love the feeling of
lack they love and they really hate it
but there it's just that programming
that idea that I'm going to get hold ESS
or fulfillment through whatever [__]
object X that I'm going to get it's just
a [__] stupid script which is made of
perfection and love because everything
is that it's made of Freedom it's
Freedom running a script that's saying
that through pursuing something xob I
will be
free Freedom running the script by
pursuing X object and attaining xob
through whatever has to be done I will
then be free and that's Freedom that's
saying
that so that's the game that's being
played and
it's it's beautiful and perfect and it's
[__]
[__] so the question simple question
is just where are you going it's a
simple
question not a complicated question not
a a super metaphysical question just a
simple easy ordinary question where are
you going where are you
going like what are you doing with your
time with your with your energy with
your with your with the body's movement
like where is it going what does it want
what is it
doing because it's obvious that it's
just running some scripts or some
programs which is okay I'm going to earn
some amount of money every year or uh to
pay for my basic needs or and then try
to earn more uh items on top of that or
it's running some script which is that I
need Way Beyond that and so now I'm
going to get into this millionaire or
multi-millionaire or billionaire league
and I'm going to get up there and when I
get up there then I will be fulfilled
and then Etc and there's all kinds of
diluted ideologies about okay well I'm
going to become a billionaire so that I
can become an
altruist so [__] kingom just be
wholeness that's it just be wholeness
that's it just be wholeness every
conversation just be wholeness okay
there's no separation there's only
caring about love and basic needs and
abundance and freedom for all bodies
that's it that's the only script or idea
that runs from the waterfall of
wholeness as as architecting wholeness
otherwise it's just architecting
separation and anxiety and War and all
of this absolute
nonsense I'm not sure um who's being
mentioned in the in the live chat no I'm
not sure I'm familiar with them and this
is another thing is
that you know a lot of the content in
this video
is there will be engagement with live
chat in one not and there's just going
to be just continue just communicating
whatever is flowing and
um it's good that there was some sort of
a flow here like just moving through
this one because this one is a
[__] it's just wholeness and then the
apparent antithesis of wholeness which
is me and that's all that's
happening there's nothing nothing else
that's
happening wholeness and the apparent
antithesis of
wholeness which is me
lacking creating mutually assured
destruction through separation
[Music]
war and there's wholeness which is not
an entity it's non local it's everything
everywhere at once and it's Universal
love everything's always coming from
that place and then it's distorted into
a contracted sense of
me apparently
another comment in the live chat just
chilling in heaven yes
sirm never left can't ever leave always
Paradise always
Paradise just mundane
ordinary
appearance
these [__] [__] ideas programs
and scripts have just run absolutely a
muck and are just proliferating like
cancer throughout
society and it's beautiful cuz it's all
Perfection apparently contracted into
its sense of lack but that sense of of
lack is gorgeously uh in
uh Rat
[Music]
Race more more more I don't have it I
don't have it I don't have it I don't
have it and meanwhile that whole time
it's literally sitting in it it's always
sitting in it it's never left it it's
always the empty and the wholeness
that's always and already it's always
that and these these ideas and programs
that are run muck are the bombs the wars
the separation the billionaires the
extravagance and luxury the portrayal of
that as a meme that then must be
attained by those that are peasants or
nobodies meanwhile actually the
nobodies The Peasants the poor the
working
class especially the ones that have low
profiles or are Anonymous those are
actually the ones that are just normies
they're just normal just
absolutely ordinary ordinary doesn't
necessarily mean that there's a complete
recognition by nothing that it's no
one but
that it's just clear that the nobodies
are actually the whole they're just the
whole they're just sitting as the hole
they're just waiting like okay so
there's only the whole and yet it's in
its duded mutually assured destruction
fight and so the nobody's just you know
just sit back like in a way waiting for
somebody in a way to approach them and
be like oh my God I lack and I need to
go find it and nobody's like dude you
don't lack KN anything you're already
whole and complete there's only the
whole already and it's perfect and free
and then that someone can kind of
release or or feel relief back into this
boundless space and infinitude that it
actually
is and then it'll stop that stupid
[__] pattern and another thing that
the body apparently does from this place
of wholeness is that it just builds for
the future of basic needs and freedom
and abundance for all just setting
Bodies free getting out of this stupid
Matrix
Society I yeah I just answered those
questions in the live chat with what I
was just talking
about because the first of all there's
nobody that's deciding anything it's
already just Freedom itself it's just
Universal flow itself but the universal
flow is the whole it's the whole it's
not separate there's no
separate names there's none of that
there's only the nameless which is the
whole which is everything and there's
that and you're
that and no one's doing anything so if
there's an appearance of this character
that's talking about wholeness and
talking about asking a question where
are you going then that's just what's
appearing if there's an appearance of oh
I'm a sense of me and I live in a world
of others and I lack and I need to take
all these courses and get all these
attainments and I don't care how I get
there if that's happening then that's
happening and that's still Perfection
happening as that there's no one
choosing it or doing it it's just what's
arising these words aren't being
appropriated and controlled by the body
it's just the flow of water the words
themselves are not different at all than
the flow of water it's literally an
equivalent or the
wind it's literally the same thing it's
the same thing the Universal Music
that's playing for no one it's playing
for no one and
everyone
um question about uh thoughts to share
on resonance or harmonics or
simatics
um one way to frame what's been talked
about is that there's that there's
wholeness and then there's the apparent
anti- wholeness which is me and one way
to frame that is in a in a perspective
of
harmonics the whole is the frequency of
you could say whatever is the sort of
solar Punk utopian decentralized basic
needs abundant Free People future that
free energy free
everything so there's a certain you
could say there's a certain harmonics
there and then there's a certain
harmonics to the sense of me that is the
apparent contraction which is oh my God
I lack and then that just [__]
mutually assur destruction dystopia Mad
Max whatever elisium whatever the
bullshitt [__] possible okay and
they're both the same thing they're not
even two different things they're the
same thing but there's only that
wholeness that has all of this beautiful
abundant futuristic potential for the
whole and then there's the apparent
contracted of that into the
dystopic and so there's a harmonic
analogy and I mean it's also obvious in
the way that that water is falling or
the wind's
blowing or in a way that those birds are
chirping or in a way that those dolphins
are swimming or whatever you want to
describe there's that Perfection
frequency and then there's the [__]
apparent deluded human that's contracted
in a body that lacks frequency and that
frequency is mutually assured
destruction here's the thing there's a
question about Free Will and and then
see this is the thing there's all that's
happening right now is just sounds if
you were a dog would you have a question
about free will or determinism or any of
that conceptual
[__]
it's just conceptual
masturbation all it is is philosophers
and scientists and spiritual people are
all just masturbating to each other's
dicks and clits that's all that it is a
dog has zero
questions be a [__] dog
woof that's your
answer the zero questions the zero ideas
of that innocent [__]
baby it's just wholeness that's all it
is there's no stupid questions or ideas
none of
them oh my God are there levels of
consciousness no you dumb ass does a dog
ask that question no no there's
not there's not you can create endless
stories about levels of consciousness
and attainments and Journeys and all
kinds of conceptual dualities and you'll
spend in you'll spend forever forever
forever symbolizing forever symbols are
endless symbols are endless and a dog
doesn't give a
[__] there is only creativity there's a
question about leaving room for create
for human creativity there's only
Universal creativity there's only that
everything is universal creativity
there's nothing besides that and there's
no controller or doer of that Universal
creativity there's only that whole
Universal creativity which is you which
is that whole which is no one every
waning that's
it
so funny all these all these ideas in
the chat okay so this is again just more
ideas and more conceptuality cuz there's
no there's no what what is even there's
a sense the qu I thought of having a
sense of wonder was a good thing that
most people
lack it just is okay it just is there's
already no one there asking the question
and there's no one there to control
whether there's going to be a sense of
wonder or a sense of lack it's just
going to be the universal water flowing
it's just going to be the wind moving
it's just going to be that okay there's
no one that's going to be controlling it
or doing it
okay so these words are not coming from
the manifestation of a body that's
controlling these words they're just the
universal emptiness
appearing as the beautiful perfect
Freedom that it is
already and wonder may arise Wonder may
arise lack may arise there's no
hierarchy of what's better than what
this isn't saying that there's a
hierarchy and wholeness is better than
lack that's not what's being said all
that's being said is that wholeness is
the only thing that is and then within
that is the apparent lack and that
apparent lack is what apparently creates
mutually assured destruction okay that's
all that's being said and through this
message of what's being said maybe that
ucer sense of lack will hear it and
it'll relax a bit and it'll stop
creating mutually assured destruction
and it'll create from holess that's all
that's being shared here and no one's
doing it
there's a question about how do we get
so distorted there's no answer there's
no answer unfuck yourself by un asking
the
question unfuck yourself by un asking
question you'll spend forever trying to
reverse engineer your way to wholeness
there is no reverse engineering your way
to wholeness there's only already
wholeness and you can make up all kinds
of stories and ideas about how there was
conditioning or how there was Distortion
and all kinds of
[__] and all kinds of oh healing and
transformation and all kinds of [__] but
no one's is doing it no one's doing it
it's just what's appearing to happen
it's just that okay it's just
that because here's the thing if if
there's if there's nothing that's saying
that there's a way to be nothing or
there's a way to beess there's a way to
overcome the Distortion as soon as
that's said there's Duality and whatever
is said next let's say nothing says that
oh it was it was uh it was uh standing
out in the middle of the sun on one foot
while playing a harmonica or something
and then boom the
conditioning dissolved and wholeness was
seen by
nothing that then what will happen is
then there will be a whole new new age
spirituality movement to try to stand in
the sunlight
uh let's add naked to it naked standing
in the sunlight on one leg playing the
harmonica to try to dissolve your
conditioning and that's the whole
spiritual industrial complex in a
nutshell is bouncing around between
experience to experience to course to
course to program to program to Guru to
Guru to psychedelic to religion to book
to concept and it's endlessly doing that
forever in a spiritual industrial
complex that's polluted by the same
[__] capitalistic me
infrastructure and it'll never end it'll
always be stuck in that little circle
doing its thing because there is no way
to reverse engineer to wholeness it's
just what's happening it's already whole
and it's just what's happening if
there's an apparent contraction it is
apparently relaxing or
relieving out of its identification with
me name location time space entity
nonsense nonsense [__] [__] lack
lack mutually ass destruction it's re
it's apparently relaxing out of
that there's a question about what
created the medicine architecture
computer technology was it individuals
it's just the universe is just the whole
it's just that there's no difference
there's no difference there's no
it's just a universal water that's
pouring through this mouthpiece that's
pouring through these fingers whatever
it's inventing whatever it's
saying we're just addicted to the
Paradigm of separation and separate
individuals and separate mes with their
separate names that are all separate
doers and therefore it's so addicting to
constantly be like oh well that was no
it was always and only the universe it
was always always and only the
whole there are no entities there's only
the
whole there's no entities it doesn't
matter what [__] word you use to
describe it I don't care if you use
Universe God absolute perfection
unconditional love it doesn't [__]
matter what word you
use you can say butthole everything is
butthole
[Music]
everything is
butthole and we're talking about the
same
thing if butthole is your way to
describe nothing
everything then it's butthole
great [__] ridiculous
dude I I love the community I love the
live chat I love it all it's just that
no amount of questions or concepts or
elaborations or any of that [__] will
address the wholeness and nothingness
that is everything in that is already
there it's already free inside it's
already free inside okay and it's free
everywhere okay and that's what you
which is nothing are you're everything
all ready that and there's only that
there's only that wholeness there's no
individual there's no me there's no
sense of lack there's no path way to
mutually assure destruction there's no
reverse engineering that contraction
back to wholeness there's only already
only Freedom there's only that just shut
the [__] up for a
second and stop [__] going places
stop chasing
[__]
it's already here it's already
this that's
it that's literally
it there's nowhere to go it's it
already
there's a question about how it's how
it's come to the this realization
okay so funny sometimes it's like how
many times does this have to be said
there is no
realization okay there's only what
already was the baby when it was
apparently born is no different than the
dog or the cat it's innocent it doesn't
have any ideas it's already non-local it
doesn't even have a name okay it doesn't
have time the baby itself doesn't have
time okay all of that [__] is just
added on ideas that then contract the
body into an entity into a time into a
location into separation into mutually
sh destruction into lack into all of
that fabricated [__] it's just an
illusion It's Just an Illusion it's a
[__] dream that's what it is
okay so it's not a realization it's not
a realization it's what already is it
it's already here here it is
already Yes lots of joy in giving and
expressing love absolutely but don't buy
in to the capitalistic [__] because
this is is what will happen is there
will be another holiday that comes up
and there will be the oh well I'm not a
worthy boyfriend or husband or whatever
[__] son or or father or whatever if
I don't or mother or whatever if I don't
uh acrew tens of thousand thousands
hundreds thousands tens of thousands or
even more dollars to buy this this
special gift [__] it's all just
[__] [__] it's [__] it's all
propagandistic [__] and it
[__] it just hooked it's just hooked
it's just
hooked and the body is just autonomously
moving to [__] fulfill a sense of
lack that's not there and then just that
little bit of [__] here's a video
here's the question where are you going
it's just like softening that uh where
am I going what is this what what is
it
oh a I don't actually lack
anything I'm already [__]
whole
huh damn I just want to play I just want
to have fun I just want to be joyous and
be innocent and build holistically for
the future of all children to be
abundant and free
I mean dude this [__] is not [__]
rocket science it's not [__] rocket
science and you don't have to get into
all kinds of metaphysical narratives
about oh I came here to bring wholeness
to Earth or whatever [__] it doesn't
[__] matter all of that meaning
masturbation just let go of all of it
let go of all of it okay it's already
here it's already here it's already
apparent happening and it's already
obvious there's only there's only
apparent there's one thing that's
happening and it can apparently look
like two that one thing that's happening
is that it's already wholeness and it
can apparently look like there's a
contraction and a sense of me that lacks
and is on a path for mutually sure
destruction that's all that's happening
that's all that's happening forever
forever that's all that's happening
there's either the whole or there is
mutually assured destruction which is
apparent Le the
whole mutually assured destruction is
nothing but a contraction of wholeness
that's another way to say it mutually
assured destruction is nothing but a
contraction of
wholeness it's wholeness appearing like
mutually assured
destruction
yes there's not it's not a realization
because there's nobody to realize
anything
yes and wish my ex-girlfriend would have
understood
that
[Music]
oh yeah man the see and this is the
thing is that there's a there's a
[__] perversion perversion
programming that's running in the
culture because then you have you have
the girls the girlfriends or the wives
or the whatever they're running
delusional programs pressuring the male
bodies to become
multi-millionaires so I don't know if
you've seen any of these [__] stupid
videos that are circulating around which
are like you know basically women that
are saying that my man better get me a
half million doll ring and my man better
make six figures seven figures eight
figures all that [__] because that is
duded programming which is then mutually
sure destructive diluted programming
which is then feedback looping into the
mutually assured destructive programming
of the maale bodies which is now
watching all these stupid memes saying
oh well I'm never going to get worthy if
I don't make millions of dollars and
then get my S my one day to be wife a
half million doll
ring and that and that's where all of
this mutually assured destructive
Tendencies comes from is that
so the the male body that
slaps that that deluded programming
awake or the female body that slaps that
diluted programming
awake that's Kali that's that's the
destroyer of the delusion back into the
wholeness that always
was back into the
nondu essence of what this
is
this another question that's why gay men
are more enlightened
yeah yeah or whatever it is I mean here
there's been a lot of open sexuality it
doesn't [__] matter if it's female
bodies or male bodies it doesn't [__]
matter but there's that level of
openness where it just doesn't [__]
matter it's no longer a little box it's
no longer saying that okay okay well I'm
going to I'm going to only go a certain
direction you know whatever it is it's
just [__] chaotic and open and
boxless and boundless and it doesn't
matter if this face is in the [__]
the
butthole of a male body or of a female
body or if a female or male body no
matter what size it doesn't matter if
it's a little twig or if it's a [__]
big big body that's eating this body's
[__] it doesn't [__] matter it
just doesn't matter just put your tongue
in an [__] that's all that
matters oh
man and and a good chunk of this deluded
programming is just breaking all of
these elusory bounds they're just the
delusion they're just a delusion you
know you look at any that two two ided
War the delusion is that there's one
side and another side and that one side
is better than the other side that's the
only delusion because obviously there's
only the perfect hole that is arising or
making up that artificial duality of
separation and then the artificial
duality of better or worse it's just too
simple man it's too ordinary and too
simple it's like a dog truly it's like a
dog or it's like a baby or like an
indigenous child that never got
programmed with this nonsense that
obviously knows that there's only the
whole it's just too
obvious it's obvious there's only the
sky that is apparently earthing there's
only um the water that's apparently
flowing or the wind that's apparently
blowing that's all that there
is does Jordan Peterson really exist or
is he construct of our Collective
imagination here here here's the thing
okay who whatever name you insert there
is just a body that's all it is right so
it's all it is whatever wrote that
question is nothing bodying this is
nothing bodying whatever uh X name you
write there is just nothing bodying it's
all nothing bodying
okay that's how it's all the same that's
how it's all flat that's how it's all
love that's how it's all Perfection and
freedom that's how it's all
that as soon as there's all these kinds
of Fabrications about oh my God all
these separate names and the separate
names to the separate bodies and certain
ones are smarter than certain other ones
and certain ones are better or more
right than certain other ones that's
where all Bombs all war all nonsense
kicks in
and by the way that doesn't mean that
there's not an apparently better surgeon
or whatever or an apparently better
basketball player it just is what it is
but it's no longer so obsessively
contracted as some sort of hierarchy of
what is best and what is worse and who's
okay to kill because of
that
there a caroak quote about uh beginning
to appear like everyone in the world is
going to think the same way as the Zen
lunatics uh laughter on their dust
lips by the way this isn't about getting
people in the world people in the world
that to think a certain way this is
absolutely not about that not about that
at all and um yes there's certain
there's a certain frequency of Zen
lunatic that that could be called this
or whatever um but it literally doesn't
matter it just doesn't matter what it's
called it could be called butthole it
doesn't [__] matter
okay you know and it's not about getting
the world to to to come from wholeness
it's not about that that does that
literally doesn't matter it's already
wholeness and Perfection yet this body
is speaking and saying the words it is
and there might be
that release or relief of that
contraction in the body which is where
am I going where am I going oh oh
oh I can get I can get wholeness I can
get fulfillment and I don't
care who I kill along the way that can
relax and if that relaxes it will be an
an easier more flow let's say
shepherding of this new Earth
architectures
here all right we going to wrap up soon
um let's just take some time to to just
sit back in what we were talking about
earlier which is just that this is
already
it so the question where are you going
can there just be sitting in a
chair can there just be laying down in
bed can there just be walking in the
Sun can there just be breathing
there can there just be hearing these
words can there just be
that can there just be that without it
happening to a sense of
me can there just be that happening for
no one for
nothing as Freedom
itself
so the question where are you
going is only applicable to the
restlessness of me
that
lack and that is on path to mutually
sure
destruction it also applies to the
restlessness of me
that
lacks and that is looking
under every single Rock in the form of
books or
concepts ideas Retreats
psychedelics gurus experiences
objects to try to find what's not
missing to try to find the nothing that
it already
is
the question where are you going does
not apply to wholeness that already
is it does not apply to nothing because
it's already free it doesn't need to ask
that question
the question arises as a reflection to
itself of where are you
going what's up with this meing this
lacking this
Waring this separation this anxiety this
non
holism it's just a
reflection and is it actually truly what
is or is it just a duded idea or program
that's been conditioned and that's
running the show
that's moving the
body to try to
fulfill what is
already empty and
whole it can never be
gotten it can never be
gotten because it already
is
so wherever you
go it's already the
case no matter if it's sitting in a
chair or if it's running like a maniac
to spend the next thousands of dollars
on the next
object to try to get fulfillment or try
to get truth try to get the nothing and
freedom that already is
so as you can probably tell some of
these videos will
be some sort of a blend between um the
non-d DU wisdom of a what was what was
used there a Zen
lunatic uh but it'll also be mixed with
some very simple observations about the
nature of culture natural Dynamics and
relations that are currently apparently
unfolding and ways to um to liberate
those Contra apparent contractions back
into the wholeness and build from that
wholeness new Earth so it be some sort
of a of a mix of that
so interesting stuff fun episode
probably just chill a little
bit and um
perhaps say a couple more things but
just just chill
really because when this love is
clear when this freedom is
clear there is no movement from
lack
and therefore no movement from me or
from separation and therefore only
movement from the whole for the
[Music]
whole
I was just thinking about the thumbnail
and what will probably be some sort of a
like
craz like chicken with its head cut off
human running around in Rat Race
circles
e
beautiful thanks for tuning
in infinite
love